it is
not only right but responsible to
revisit the balance of risks and
opportunities that guided our original
decision last year
while vaccination remains our very best
line of defense against covert 19 i
believe that it is no longer
proportionate to require vaccination as
a condition of deployment through
statute
so madam deputy speaker today i am
announcing that we will launch a
consultation on ending vaccination as a
condition of deployment in health and
all social care settings
subject to the responses and the will of
this house the government will revoke
the regulations
i have always been clear that our rules
must remain proportionate and balanced
and of course should we see another
dramatic change in the virus it would be
only responsible to review this policy
again
madam deputy speaker some basic facts
remain of course
vaccines
save lives
and everyone working in health and
social care has a professional duty to
be vaccinated against cobit 19. so while
we will seek to end vaccination as a
condition of deployment in health and
social care settings using statute i am
taking the following steps
first
i have written to professional
regulators operating across health to
ask them to urgently review current
guidance to registrants on vaccinations
including covert 19 to emphasize their
professional responsibilities in this
area
second i have asked the nhs to review
its policies on the hiring of new staff
and the deployment of existing staff
taking into account their vaccination
status
and third i've asked my officials to
consult on updating my department's code
of practice which applies to all cqc
registered providers of all healthcare
and social care settings in england they
will consult on strengthening
requirements in relation to covert 19
including reflecting the latest advice
on infection protection control
and
finally madame deputy speaker
our vital work to promote the uptake of
vaccines continues and i'm sure the
whole house will want to join me in
thanking nhs trust and care providers
for their relentless efforts in putting
patient safety first
madam deputy speaker i also wish to
thank the shadow health secretary and
the party opposite for their support of
the government's approach to this policy
area
one of the reasons that we have the
highest vaccine uptake rates in the
world is because of the confidence our
vaccines that comes the confidence that
comes from this place from all sides of
the house
we may not agree on everything but when
it comes to vaccination together we have
put the national interest first
it is now in our national interest to
embark on this new phase of the pandemic
where we keep the british people safe
while showing the world how we can
successfully learn to live with covert
19 i commend this statement to the house